this guy is the most of the [__] guy of
all time
okay are you working bro you got plenty
cash plenty
I'm gonna put you on my way I got
somebody for y'all you know what I'm
saying bro I mean hair is a hat you know
with a brim yeah tight
you like black white I like white girls
more better okay
so could not I like white girls more
better
words
in other words POG pod that's what I
like yeah why are you being a politician
about it in other words Park
say that video say it one more time I'll
say it slow
hog
p-a-w-g badass white girls
we gonna hold you up [__] to do not
someone dude they're so trolling him
does he know this guy is so a guy I
would be friends with in high school in
New Jersey I can't even believe it dude
I would uh my name right here Joshua
Henderson
all right bro all right bro forget that
taking it our name be the last thing
you'll ever hear I'm getting a little
bit out of the word bro all right bro
are you taking it what's his mouth doing
dude in the middle of the guy's talking
just like
don't forget about it ever
okay I gotta go back to that part dude
that's my favorite part
I mean that is so funny to me hold on
come on
okay here we go oh the snow rabbit here
we go yeah other [__] so what's your
name again bro before we go bro cause we
gotta go man ain't gonna lie together we
ain't gonna hold you up I ain't gonna
lie to you what's your name here my name
Joshua Henderson
all right bro oh you're swallowing so
much forget that may my name be the last
time singing voice bro all right bro all
right you take it easy now bro
forget about it
Barack Obama a little bit
and your [__] don't forget about it
however
um
dude that guy
is so dope God I would be that guy's
friend so hard you can tell he's got the
worst breath of all time um I mean
there's no question that that boy or man
whatever he is has the worst breath of
all time and it's okay but Joshua
Henderson is [__]
oh oh his profile he is so dope I mean
the [__] picture in the thing
what is it a regular video of his like
okay he's just dancing all right
well this guy's getting oh here we go
well it's not just pogs I like King
I like huge chungas too
as a member okay huge chungus um
you know what is this guy saying here
what's up y'all oh I wanted to ask y'all
something um y'all think I'm
light-skinned or not
I mean wow
Izzy light-skinned dead
um
fat ass white girls
congratulations
[Music]